- Sometimes when guys talk about,
you know, when they realize
they have the respect of their peers,
they felt vindicated.
They can remember, like, a specific guy
saying something to them, and they said,
"Oh, when he knew I was nice,
- Wow.
- I knew I was nice."
- That's a great—that's…
- Is there someone like that for you?
- Yeah.
And it's crazy. Just crazy. That's…
One person who
my rookie year told me something
that stuck with me—
I don't even know if he remember
this—is Michael Redd.
He told me I was gonna be special
in this league. Keep, keep,
don't stop. Like,
I just remember those words so vividly.
You gonna be special in this league.
Don't stop. Keep working. It was my rookie year,
Michael Redd.
I never got the chance to tell him
thank you for that. He might,
he may not even remember.
- Yeah.
- But Michael Redd
told me those words,
and it stuck with me to this day.
- Really?
Why do you think in that moment, like, that
was so, it resonated so deeply for you?
- I don't know. At that time, you know,
he was a veteran.
You know, he was an established player.
He was a player, like, I've always been
a fan of the game of basketball.
'70s, '80s, '90s.
So I always respected
all the older guys.
- Mmhmm.
- Honest.
I respected what Michael Redd did
in the league.
And I don't know.
It was just that moment where he pulled me
to the side and, you know,
I felt how genuine he was about it,
you know what I mean? Because even at that point,
my rookie year, you know,
you deal with so many emotions
questioning, like, damn, "When am I gonna be good?
When Imma be able to be myself
and be comfortable?" Like, I'm
only 19 years old playing with grown men.
So for him to pull me to the side
and acknowledge something
towards me that I was feeling
iffy about was all I needed.
- Shoutout Michael Redd.
- I love that.